[Music]
hey rob randy from south carolina
you've mentioned several times that
you're a big dodgers fan great sports
fan
so if you became a major league
player what would your walk-up song
be and why it's got to be a good one
it's got to get everyone on their feet
to cheer for rob lowe when he comes to
bat
let's hear it well randy from south
carolina i am a dodger fan
in fact i am going to a dodger game the
minute i'm done
talking to you um and randy i'll have
you know i've spent a lot of time
thinking about this a lot a lot of time
in fact i i commute so much in my car
that one of the games that i play is
switching channels and whatever channel
that
comes on that has to be my walk-up song
and then just loving the debacle
that that inevitably becomes like that's
the song i have to walk up to
so that's a good by the way i'm giving
you a good game if you want to have a
good game and you're boarding your car
you're like with your kids like all
right all right junior this is going to
be your walk-up song you ready
you turn it in whatever song it is
that's his walk-up song all right honey
it's really fun but that said um
i mean
i think i'm gonna go with um
maybe eminence front
um sweet emotion
[Music]
um and and maybe and there's a
part it's in the there it's not the
bridge but there there's a very specific
part of
baba o'reilly and won't get fooled again
um and then if i really wanted to [ __ ]
someone's head up
it would be the opening to um
give me shelter put that in your pipe
and smoke it randy
those are good ones huh huh then you can
choose you get to choose which one of
them
thanks to a question great question
thanks for listening